-Our next guest is
an Emmy-winning actor
you know best from his portrayal
of Logan Roy on "Succession."
His acting tutorials are
available now on BBC Maestro.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Brian Cox.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back, Brian!
-Nice to be here, as always.
-You know, I won't
spend too much time on it,
but this is the first time
I've seen you
since the end of the fantastic
show, "Succession."
-Yeah.
-And it was a season,
it ended so beautifully
and nailed the landing.
You had one of
the great lines --
and I think Logan had many
over the years --
which is,
he said to his children,
"I love you,
but you're not serious people."
-Yeah.
-That really sort of summed
it all up, didn't it?
-Yeah, well, actually
it was my favorite line
that I had to say
throughout the whole show.
-Yeah?
-I love that line.
And I just thought,
"Why didn't I say it earlier?"
-Yeah.
It's true. They certainly
were pretty unserious.
-Yeah, yeah. They were.
They were damned unserious
most of the time.
-Were you --
I do feel like we've given the
world enough time to catch up,
but are you surprised,
or how do you think Logan
would feel if he'd been around
at the fact that Tom,
in the end, won the succession?
-But I think that Logan
had already planned that.
-Yeah.
-I think he'd
already planned that.
Certainly
the Skarsgard character,
that it was all
going to go that way,
because he could see
that those children
were not going to
add up to anything.
So I think that --
-[ Laughter ]
-Well, they didn't
add up to anything.
[ Laughs ]
They added up to zilch.
Anyway, what I felt was
that I thought
that Tom was very kind to him.
You know, at one point,
he had a UTI infection,
and Tom actually helped him.
So I think that, you know --
And I thought, I think,
"Well, you have to put up
with my horrible daughter,
so I've got to give something
to reward you."
[ Crowd gasps ]
-It was a bad lot.
It was a bad lot.
Everybody's reacting like --
And they should know, these
aren't Brian's real children.
[ Laughter ]
You know, again, for those
who haven't seen, I apologize,
but Logan left us.
You know, he passed away
early in the season,
I think maybe
earlier than people thought.
-I think a lot of people --
I had people saying,
"Oh, no, I'm not going to
watch it anymore.
You've gone.
I'm not going to watch it."
I said,
"But it's called 'Succession.'"
-Yeah.
-That's the whole point
of the show.
You have to have the succession.
-Yeah.
-They kind of told you
with the title
where this was headed.
-Yes, it does.
But you know,
people can be so dumb, you know?
-
Yeah. -Come on.
Really, get it right.
-Of the three kids in the --
where are they now?
Who do you think is doing
the best in the fictional world?
-In the fictional world? I...
Well, I think they're struggling
in the fictional world.
I think they're doing very well
in the real world.
I mean, Sarah is
doing a fantastic job in London.
And Jeremy, I think,
is about to do a play here.
I don't know
what Kieran's up to,
but he's probably up to
something extraordinary.
He usually is.
So yeah, I think they're
all doing probably well.
It was an extraordinary
show to work on,
because we did really become
like a family
and we were very, very close,
and it's very odd now.
I kind of miss them.
-I would imagine.
-Yeah, you miss them.
Because it was the most
extraordinary six years.
You know, over six years,
the whole thing took place.
And Jesse was just amazing --
Jesse Armstrong, who wrote it,
and the writers,
the whole thing.
The whole job, it's probably
the best job I've ever had.
-Well, it was certainly
one of the best shows
I've ever seen,
and congratulations
to all of you.
-Yeah, it was great.
It was great.
-So BBC Maestro --
this is fantastic as well.
I've seen clips. It seems like
a perfect fit for you.
You were giving
acting tutorials, teaching.
You first started
teaching acting
when you were 24 years old?
-Yeah, yeah.
-How did that first
come to pass?
-Well, it happened,
I was doing a play
in London in the West End,
and the guy,
sadly he's no longer with us.
Mind you, it was 50 years ago,
because not many people
are with us, so...
Anyway, he said, "Would
you like to come and teach?"
And I said, "Norman."
He was called Norman.
And I said,
"Norman, I'm only 24."
He said, "No, I think
it's time that you did that.
I think you've got a lot.
You're fresh, you're new."
I was, by then, I was probably
nine years out of drama school.
And I went
and I was very lucky,
because in my first group that
I had was Dame Harriet Walter.
-Oh, my goodness.
She's fantastic.
-I know, I know.
She was one of my students.
-And that's who played
your ex-wife on "Succession."
-Who played my ex-wife
in the show,
which was kind of, you know,
we've worked together
over the years.
And then there was
another wonderful actor
who sadly died of AIDS
called Ian Charleson.
Now, Ian was,
I don't know if you remember
"Chariots of Fire"?
-Sure, of course.
-He played Eric Little.
He played the runner,
and he was a wonderful,
wonderful actor
and a great singer.
They did this big revival
of "Guys and Dolls"
and he played
Sky Masterson and was superb.
But sadly...
And he then went on
to play Hamlet,
which he didn't particularly
want to do,
because he was very ill.
And he wondered
why he wasn't asked
to do it in the first place.
And I said, you know,
"That's the way it is, Ian."
But he played it
and he literally played it
up until
two days before he died.
-Unbelievable.
-It was astonishing,
absolutely astonishing.
-And could you tell?
In a class like that, obviously,
I'm sure everyone
has a level of talent,
but can you always tell
when someone's special?
-Oh, yeah, you can.
And there are sleepers.
You know, there are people
who are going to take time,
but they have
the right attitude.
It's just that they've got to
trust themselves.
And it's all about trust.
You know, it's trusting yourself
more than anything else.
That's what makes a good actor,
is to trust who you are.
And drama school is very good
for that, finding that,
where you can learn
that trust in yourself.
That's why I believe
in drama education.
I think it's a great education,
not just for drama,
but for everything,
for life, actually.
-I also liked that --
not that you take it
too seriously,
or I guess you don't
make it more complicated
than it needs to be.
In one of the clips I saw,
you talked about
how you had trouble with lines,
learning lines,
a very tricky thing,
but one of your advice
for students was
"just learn the [bleep] lines
and don't bump
into the furniture."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's kind of
a nice one to know.
-Well, that is
the basic principle of acting.
-Yeah.
Everything after that,
it's just gravy.
-It's all kind of, you know,
it's all bollocks,
really, after that.
But don't bump
into the furniture
and learn your [bleep] lines
is what you're supposed to do.
-But that did not,
learning lines did not
come naturally to you.
-No, I was not a good learner.
It's the discipline
that I've had to --
I mean, I'm about to do
"Long Day's Journey Into Night."
-Oh, my goodness, yeah.
-I'm going to be doing that
in London in the new year.
And I'm dreading it,
because I've got to go through
the learning line process.
And as you get older,
the synapses are not quite
working in the same way.
-I know television is different,
obviously, multiple takes
than being on stage,
but I would imagine
with shows like "Succession,"
with a show like "Deadwood,"
where they're
so beautifully written
but in a way that you haven't
heard people speak before.
So you might think it might
be unnatural to learn.
But does beautiful writing make
the learning process easier?
-Oh, of course.
Of course, because
if there's a poetic element
to the writing,
you immediately go to that.
And that's why
Shakespeare is so great,
because it's structured
so wonderfully well.
I mean, free prose
is very hard to learn,
especially a lot
that's interrupted,
when you're doing
interrupted lines
and it's not necessary.
But free prose is difficult.
But Shakespeare,
anything that's got a poetic
bent to it, it's helpful.
-It's just wonderful
to have you teaching.
It's wonderful to have you
here in person.
-Lovely to be here.
-Brian Cox, everybody!
His acting tutorials
are available on BBC Maestro.
We'll be right back
with Da'Vine Joy Randolph.